all right I'm drilled by Johnny Reed
he's got a brand new album revival we're
gonna go through a track-by-track let's
start with Soul Train
[Music]
why was this the first track do you
subsist
what is going to be the first song on
the record we in order to record every
record needs a whole club might need
something to get it started you know
yeah and we were talking I was talking
to a good friend of mine ah but the
music that I grew up with and it was
show music you know and he said like
Soul Train I said exactly a jumped on
that Soul Train a long time ago and I
have never got off the Soul Train so
that's what that's my surely sparked the
the rating process is Soul Train the
first Lane you know pick it bought me a
ticket when I was just a boy right and
it just talks about the journey of
getting on this train and not getting
happy of a woman every record ever
recorded there's always a song or two on
there that's dedicated to the woman I'm
a leaf whether it'll be my granny my
mother my wife or even my daughter you
know it talks about the greatest gift
that God ever gave me it's wrapped up in
the heart of a woman it's just really
just a song a dedication and devotion
so is this to all the women in your life
or to a specific woman I think it's just
all the woman in the world I mean I
think yeah I think we need to be
thankful you know where would we be
without love to be honest you know so
that's it's really just a song of
dedication for for the love that they
get was you know Memphis
[Music]
[Music]
Memphis about good friend of mine
Hammond is we boys we run home and we'd
watch top of the parks and we have all
these dreams that gone in Memphis and
you know who's to know who's to know
that I was gonna move and that I would
be spending a lot of time in Memphis he
number that each turn lava pool whiskey
kisses
keep on whiskey kisses is a lot of
people have asked me what's whiskey
kisses is up at whiskey yeah it's not
it's not about whiskey it's the whiskey
is uh it's the whiskey is love you know
don't forget about it you know don't put
on a shelf and forget a butter you know
bring it done dust off the bottle and
have yourself some feet and shoulders
my mother gave me my mother's a Catholic
and she gave me this read medallion a
long time ago she and Christopher and I
keep it my passport and it fell it one
day and I'm on a plane and I looked and
I and I just hit that separation area
song but other people that need help you
know get on my shoulders
I'll cutting you through the deepest a
dark my stand the bluest of blue and
that's the scanner that was a motivation
behind the lyrics of a song yeah she
just wants to dance
[Music]
my daughter loves to dyers the dance and
there is an old there's a song by kept
more and after to cover songs on this
album and one of them is she just wants
to dance we did a mere upbeat version of
the song but Eva loves it and I was like
I'm playing on the wreck of just showed
all unlicensed America to no good yeah
the the light in you
[Music]
[Music]
the lady knew is about you and I it's
about the other people you know it's a
bit Fame than the goodness it's a bit
Shane and not Lee you know regardless a
coach of color creed religion you know
surety bringing out the best in people
and you know lighten up the wouldn't
it's above a a dream scenario but I
think it's a very realistic thing I
think he can happen it's really just a
social document never loved another
[Music]
never love another I wrote we all in
through the glass Tiger Hammond I sat
down with it a wee cup of tea and we
started groovin and it just fella never
loved another I would I could never tell
another lover there's no because I love
you yeah I'm blank page
Esmeralda chosen
flight page is it's a bit a love story
it's a book my relationship with my wife
and in the relationship the route that
we have with people it starts with a
blank page it says it starts with a
hello and workshop man yeah you know
that's how it starts and it's about the
story of love and and what a beautiful
story that is when it's true every time
I roll the dice
[Music]
Delbert McClinton Kovar every time I
roll the days loved Elba always have
loved Elbe and I've always loved this
song and I knew my audience would love
this song yeah as much as you do
probably more right you know because
there we've got a great valves in that
you know cry no more
[Music]
I know more there's a song that I've had
for many years it's a very heavy song
I've got a lot of people in my life that
I'm sure you know I'm sorry shelf up to
alcoholism and that it's a song but the
relationship between an alcoholic in a
bottle heaviest song that I've ever put
on any of my record but I just felt that
this was the right team it was the rate
album to tell the story and the hopes
that people would be able to realize
that I'm not alone and there's other
people in the world they go they go
through these these situations you know
regret for two years
[Music]
I repair everywhere
[Music]
regret is exactly that it's the one
thing in life that we all have you know
it's a true story you know my my father
left his mother to come to Canada I he
regrets leaving I think he regrets a lot
of the time he spent away you know when
I was growing up I think we all have
their debts and it's a song that it
talks about not forgetting that but
moving forward on a positive way and
loving with no regrets
right don't let the green grass fool you
[Music]
don't let the green grass fool you as a
cover song by Walker pick up the one of
my favorite songs and I was involved
team and it was a PC it just and a great
song and I think a great message yeah
you know sometimes you gotta just stay
where you are don't let you know don't
think it's better over there because
it's not right you've got it yeah that's
a little book that's amazing thank you
thank you very sure that too